à mary jo gars à 10 ans ausy à garcia 10
ans un garçon génial et plein de vie
disent ses proches rocé flores juniors
10 ans en 4e année un amateur de
baseball un grand frère et man eva
miralles 44 ans enseignante depuis 17
ans tuée lexie rubio 10 ans avait
remporté un prix quelques heures avant
le drame une distinction célébré en
compagnie de ses parents qui l'ont vu
pour la dernière fois
oui d'harmoniser les gothys dorures des
parents qui à la fin de l'année scolaire
devront planifier des funérailles au
lieu de planifier des vacances la petite
ville de 6000 habitants pleure ses
enfants et leurs enseignants
et 10 venu porter des fleurs mais il est
vrai qu'il y ait plus que des prières
qu'on l'ait qu enfin
j'espère mettre un peu de pression pour
changer les lois des ti pour que ce type
d'armes ne se retrouvent plus entre les
mains d'enfants et de personnes perturbé
mentalement
pour le moment le gouverneur du texas
dit n'avoir aucune indication que le
tueur avait un passé criminel ou de
délinquance ni qu'il souffrait de
troubles mentaux par contre il avait
annoncé six actes sur facebook
sur balles et
un discours qui ne passe pas auprès de
l'ancien représentant du texas le
démocrate ben et o'rourke interrompt le
point de presse
le maire de la ville l'invectivé
scène
c'est indécent de parler de santé
mentale alors qu'on autorise un jeune de
18 ans avoir un fusil à air 15 ceci est
une ligne du lot mais croire marcheurs
la santé mentale n'est pas le seul la
question beaucoup plus sur
l'accessibilité aux armes à feu
la législation aux états unis sur le
contrôle des armes à feu et variables
d'un état à l'autre
la question demain elle est très
polarisée à l'instar des élites
politiques et le président bailly donne
par exemple introduit deux projets de
loi pour convertir et le pas son jeu
très très modeste dans le contrôle des
armes à feu les deux projets de loi
semble la grande majorité des américains
même ceux qui possèdent une arme
aimerait un meilleur encadrement
d'autres continue d'invoquer le deuxième
amendement introduit au xviiie siècle
par les pères fondateurs pour se
protéger contre une armée
professionnelle
d'autres encore pleurent leurs morts à
chaque tuerie ici s mitraillette radio
canada montréal